evault et silence dans la classe j'avais
entendu ce que j'ai dit ça suffit euh
j'ai repéré vous un
bon ça suffit
aujourd'hui nous allons faire une dictée
et nous sommes le 26 c'est ça le 26 août
bien
le gaz et
le président c'est le titre
le gas in et des thons rouges des
virgules
lorsque sont revues à bâle en valais
point virgule mais est venu parce que le
vide et est devenu
il a enfin à la pêche à la ligne
pour un résistant crocheter points et
étant costaud mais ouvrez la parenthèse
quoi qu tout pout but c'est son problème
fermez la parenthèse et en l'effective
en définitive hélas à crédit il a en
fait le point final
relisez
bon moi
je peux aller au 0 beau
gens aussi vos je suppose qu'il a plus
place au cerveau
le
but des travaux 18 tu seras un homme mon
fils